vor fünf jahren blickten wir begeistert
gegen osten und feierten die ersten
knospen des arabischen frühlings doch
nur wenige monate später kam es in kairo
zu gewaltexzessen unter den
demonstranten und zu
massenvergewaltigungen
der demokratische prozess machte ganz
offenbar halt vor der gleichheit der
geschlechter die silvester nachdem köln
hat die debatte um das frauenbild
arabischer männer nun neu entfacht
welchen stellenwert hat die frau im
arabischen raum und lassen sich die
herrschenden rollenbilder verändern
diese fragen stehen im zentrum der
heutigen sternstunde philosophie
herzlich willkommen bei mir im studio
ist jetzt für ihn el fekki sie bereiste
fünf jahre lang die arabische welt und
hat dabei wortwörtlich den
schlafzimmerblick gewagt sie sprach mit
den menschen vor ort über ihre
sexualität und über geschlechterrollen
und sie zum schluss gekommen wenn sich
im bett nichts ändert verändert sich
auch politisch nichts hätte es ein
ereignis wie die kölner silvesternacht
in den arabischen ländern überhaupt in
die zeitung geschafft
natürlich sorgte dass in den arabischen
medien für schlagzeilen in tv und presse
im ganzen arabischen raum
da hatten wir ähnliche vorkommnisse
sexuelle belästigung in der
öffentlichkeit dienen thema einer
lebhaften öffentlichen debatte sind in
ägypten und im ganzen arabischen raum
darüber berichtet ich glaube in den
arabischen medien gab es eine gewisse
beunruhigung
nun sind die arabischen medien natürlich
sehr unterschiedlich aber es gab eine
gewisse aufregung und sorge über die art
wie die sache dargestellt wurde
in dem sinn dass eine relativ kleine
anzahl von männern und nordafrikanischer
abstammung und ihr klar inakzeptables
verwerfliches verhalten von gewissen
wiesen in wesentlichen und speziell in
europäischen medien benutzt wurde um
gewissermaßen zu verallgemeinern
die arabische männer seien im weiteren
sinn
alle muslimischen es gab ja auch in der
deutschen presse zb der versuch die
parallele zu ziehen zwischen den
vorkommnissen in köln und den sexuellen
übergriffen die sich auf dem tahrir
platz ereignet haben im rahmen des
arabischen frühlings wo sieben zu
massenvergewaltigung auch gekommen ist
finden sie diese parallele trägt etwas
bei lassen sie mich über die
vorkommnisse auf dem tahrir-platz nicht
weil ich auf dem tahrir-platz war weil
ich selber dort belästigt worden
zum glück habe ich diese art von massen
angriff wer von den frauen in köln und
auch von frauen auf dem tahir-platz
beschrieben wurde nicht selber erlebt
aber ich habe es mit eigenen augen
gesehen und weiß wie erschreckend es ist
aber ich glaube die analogie die
vergleiche zwischen den ereignissen in
köln und den tahrir platz
der tahrir platz ist interessant nicht
weil er sich in ägypten befindet und man
glaubt dass einige der angriffe in köln
von männern arabischer herkunft begangen
wurden
der tahrir platz ist interessant weil er
eines der am besten untersuchten
beispiele dafür ist was passiert bei
dieser art von massen wie man es nennen
könnte gitarrist interessant weil
verschiedene leute das dortige geschehen
näher untersucht haben die männer die
diese verbrechen begangen haben wir
verstehen jetzt viel besser was abgeht
in der dynamik dieser art massen raus
[Musik]
und die wichtige lektion vom tahrir
platz ist die verschiedenartigkeit der
männer
ja es gibt diese unseligen fälle wo
gewisse männer frauen angreifen aber
wichtig ist sich daran zu erinnern dass
unter diesen hunderttausenden von
menschen die sich auf dem tahrir
versammelt haben
auch männer waren die versucht haben
diesen frauen zu helfen
ich gebe ihnen nur ein beispiel von dem
was sich während einem der proteste auf
dem tahrir platz gesehen habe eine junge
frau wurde von einer gruppe von männern
eingegangen
ich war auf der anderen seite eines
zauns konnte also durch die gitterstäbe
zu sehen
ihr aber nicht helfen dieser frau wurden
die kleider vom leib gerissen von einer
gruppe von männern
gleichzeitig gab es auf meiner seite der
absperrung männer die verzweifelt
versuchten sega herauszuziehen
dieses beispiel zeigt dass es eine
unglaubliche vielfalt von männern gibt
und weshalb es so gefährlich ist die
inakzeptablen taten von einigen wenigen
zu verallgemeinern
und was passiert genau in einer solchen
situation also das jetzt kommt die
private personen die versuchen zu helfen
aber könnte man da auch zur polizei
gehen und diese männer anklagen single
man muss wissen dass in den letzten fünf
oder sechs jahren die ganze thematik der
sexuellen belästigung im öffentlichen
raum insbesondere in ägypten eine
wandlung durchgemacht hat als ich 2008
mit dem schreiben eines buches anfing
hätte keine frau öffentlich darüber
gesprochen dass sie sexuell belästigt
wurde oder vergewaltigt wird die debatte
viel offener geführt
dazu gehört dass frauen nun bereit sind
vorfälle zumindest der polizei zu melden
lassen sie mich erzählen was letztes
jahr beim islamischen opferfest
geschehen ist das ist eines unserer
religiösen feste wieder hunderttausende
menschen versammeln sich interessant war
dass eine große anzahl frauen ungefähr
80 der polizei tatsächlich vorkommnisse
von sexueller belästigung meldeten die
regierungen anderer präsentierten das
als riesigen fortschritt frauen werden
aktiv das problem ist schließlich haben
sich nur gerade drei frauen dafür
entschieden anklage zu erheben
es gibt verschiedene gründe erstens
haben wir jetzt ein gesetz das
sexuelle belästigung kriminalisiert aber
ein gesetz nützt nicht viel ohne mittel
zur durchsetzung der mensa wenn also die
polizei ja sie werden geschult
wir haben jetzt eine weibliche
polizeioffiziere auf streife realität
ist dabei wenn sie also zur polizei
gehen sagt man ihnen dort in den meisten
fällen das ist privatsache belästigen
sie uns nicht damit
der andere grund ist die familie sogar
mit einem juristischen apparat der die
frauen zum sprechen ermutigt der staat
das gesetz sind nicht die recken und
komponenten die das verhalten der frauen
bestimmen
sehr oft zögern sie diese fälle zu
melden weil sie angst haben vor der
reaktion ihrer familien die familien
ihre wir haben also fortschritte gemacht
doch es reicht und das war ja auch genau
der grund warum sie gesagt haben sie
nehmen sich diese zeitreisen durch die
arabischen länder sie sind eigentlich
von ägypten aus durch den maghreb in den
mittleren osten gereist während längerer
zeit wenn vielen jahren und daraus ist
eben dieses buch entstanden sie haben
bereits das buch erwähnt 6 und die
zitadelle
sie haben eigentlich nichts anderes
getan als ich gefragt woher kommen die
quellen dieses machismus dieses
patriarchats und haben gesagt dafür muss
ich mehr wissen über sex leben dieser
menschen
warum genau ist das sexleben so wichtig
geworden sie in diesem buch
lassen sie mich das erklären ich sehe
ein dass man die kfd arabischen welt
etwas ungewöhnlich ist eine gesellschaft
durch die sechs brille zu betrachten was
ich sagen wir gilt aber nicht nur für
den arabischen raum
sex ist eine unglaublich starke linse
mit dem man jede gesellschaft verstehen
gab
weil was im inneren des schlafzimmers
geschieht die machtverhältnisse draußen
widerspiegelt das ist eigentlich michel
foucault der französische eigentlich
absolut auch bezug auf ihn diese idee
dass er im grunde genommen sexualität
wie wir sexualität leben aber auch wie
wir über sexualität sprechen darüber
nachdenken die machtstrukturen einer
gesellschaft reflektieren absolut und in
der tat wäre michelle figur gibt es auch
den ausgezeichneten deutschen
psychoanalytiker wilhelm reich
in den 1930 er jahren sehr überzeugend
über den zusammenhang zwischen
autoritären regimes und sexualität
schrieb dass diktatoren jeder farben und
jeder politischen richtung 6 in religion
einbetten und das werkzeug für soziale
kontrolle nutzen speziell gegenüber
frauen und jugendlichen geld noch ein
nicht nur im arabischen raum sie finden
dass in gesellschaften überall auf der
welt
sie sagen ja auch in diesem buch in
einer stelle wenn ich sie zitieren darf
sie sagen denn sie ein volk verstehen
wollen beginnen sie mit einem blick in
die schlafzimmer
sie gehen aber eigentlich noch einen
schritt weiter sie sagen nämlich auch
wenn sie die politik verändern wollen
dann verändern sie zusammen das sexleben
absolut weil es einen zusammenhang gibt
zwischen den beiden sich bereits sagt
klar ist was draußen geschieht
beeinflusst das geschehen im inneren
aber was drinnen geschieht kann auch die
machtverhältnisse draußen beeinflussen
dazu ein gutes beispiel mein buch wurde
in verschiedenen sprachen publiziert und
rund um die welt gelesen
einer der orte wo es besonders populär
ist und sehr viele leser hat ist in die
dort stößt das buch auf großes interesse
weil viele probleme die ich im
arabischen raum beschreibe auch für
indien gelte nun wenn wir von ägypten
nach indien schauen sagen wir dort ist
die größte demokratie der welt die
älteste demokratie im globalen süden
sie haben einen rechtsstaat sie haben
meinungsfreiheit sie haben
versammlungsfreiheit
sie haben alles was es braucht das ganze
drum und dran eine demokratie von dem
wir in ägypten nur träumen können aber
ganz viel gewalt auch gegen frauen sagt
beginnen wenn sie in die schlafzimmer
hineinschauen finden sie all die
probleme und noch mehr die ich in meinem
buch beschreibe
deshalb frage ich was bedeuten diese
großen politischen strukturen wenn
demokratie freiheit menschenrechte nicht
im schlafzimmer beginnen
wir sind aktuell in einer spannenden
situationen in ägypten zum beispiel
haben wir im öffentlichen bereich nicht
viel handlungsspielraum
deshalb ist nun der private raum der
einzige ort wo wir den aufstand
vielleicht fortsetzen können
das finde ich spannend denn wenn dort
der wandel einer beginnt geht weiter
irgendwann wird er das öffentliche leben
beeinflusst
sie sind ja ursprünglich immunologin und
haben nachher als journalistin auge aber
dafür dschasira für den economy ist und
auch für die uno sie waren nämlich
stellvertretende vorsitzende der uno
kommission für hiv und das recht und in
diesem buch schreiben sie auch dass
eigentlich diese studien die ich da
gemacht haben sie die uno ihnen auch
noch einmal gezeigt hat wie wichtig dass
der sex eigentlich ist wenn man eine
gesellschaft verstehen will weil sie
herausgefunden haben dass rein die hiv
raten in den arabischen ländern auf viel
tiefer angegeben wurden auch sie
tatsächlich sind ist ein sehr guter
grund um über sex zu reden jahren im
arabischen raum viele tabus und um die
sexualität und dazu möchte ich klar
sagen es ist nicht dass wir in ägypten
oder in anderen ländern und
gesellschaften der regierung nicht über
sex sprechen würden wir sprechen die
ganze zeit übersetzt frauen sprechen mit
frauen männer mit männern
schwierig ist es das gespräch in den
öffentlichen bereich zu tragen damit man
diese diskussion öffentlich führen kann
müssen sie eine akzeptable
präsentationsraum finden ist ein sehr
sozial verträglicher weg weil sie in
gewissem sinn in den weißen kittel des
gesundheitswesens schlüpfen
das verleiht ihnen ansehen ich ziehe
also meinen weißen hiv und praxis mantel
an nicht klopft an die türen und die
leute lasst mich immer dann sehe ich den
weißen kittel aus und sprechen über den
kern der sache über sex was hiv
anbelangt besteht der eindruck dass es
im arabischen raum kein hiv gibt dass es
wegen unserer kultur und religion für
uns kein thema sei das ist schlecht
falsch wenn sie sich die statistiken
anschauen etwa jene die uranerz
publiziert gibt es zwei weltregionen wo
die hiv ansteckungen und die aids toten
immer noch zu eine davon ist der
mittlere osten und nordafrika wir haben
im moment nur in kleinen gruppen bei
menschen mit hohem risiko aber es
breitet sich aus 70 prozent der frauen
im arm
ein raum von denen wir wissen dass sie
hiv-positiv sind es ist ein
unterschätztes problem
70 prozent dieser frauen wurden von
ihren männern mit dem virus angesteckt
in der ehe einem ort wo sie sich in
sicherheit wenden
deshalb ist es wichtig hiv als
gelegenheit wahrzunehmen und über andere
unangenehme dinge zu sprechen
das ist ja auch interessant dass sie
jetzt sagen viele bekommen das hiv-virus
von ihren ehemännern obwohl das buch als
der 6
die er eigentlich nur in der zitadelle
stattfindet und die zitadelle steht ja
eigentlich eben für die ehe diese idee
die zitadelle die über kairo ton tin
zwölften jahrhundert von saladin erbaut
um gegen die kreuzritter eine festung zu
haben sehen sie hier im bild ein
wunderschönes leider noch nie in
original gesehen aber sie wohnen da ja
aber sie sehen das wahrscheinlich sehr
oft aber wenn man sich das vorstellen
sie sagen eigentlich sechs nur in der
zitadelle dann ist das eine absolute im
scheinheilige idee weil es ansonsten
würden die männer ja nicht dieses hiv
virus nach hause bringen natürlich nicht
noch einmal das ist das öffentliche
gesicht der sexualität
unser problem im arabischen raum ist das
der einzige sozial akzeptierte kontext
für sexuelle aktivitäten die die tabelle
sie wird wie eine festung verteidigt nur
dort sexuelle aktivität öffentlich
anerkannt in wirklichkeit befindet sich
ein großteil unserer bevölkerung
außerhalb citadel darunter junge
menschen die sich nicht leisten können
zu heiraten
in verschiedenen arabischen ländern
steigt das heiratsalter um ihnen ein
beispiel zu gehen in tunesien sie junge
männer durchschnittlich anfangs 30 wenn
sie heiraten
junge frauen anfangs was sollen sie tun
es ist sehr komplex aber einer der
wichtigsten gründe ist die wirtschaft
sie müssen verstehen dass sich die
wirtschaft in den arabischen ländern der
vollen wucht der globalisierung geöffnet
hat wir haben stark konsumorientierte
kulturen das problem ist dass
für die große mehrheit der bevölkerung
keine entsprechenden
einkommensmöglichkeiten habe wegen
arbeitslosigkeit auf einer der
hauptgründe für den arabischen frühling
ist die tatsache dass wir eine
zweistellige jugendarbeitslosigkeit
haben namentlich vier junge männer bei
den frauen sind die zahlen noch höher
aber wenn sie als junger mann keinen job
oder ihrer familie hat kein geld hat das
verschiedene erstmals können sie nicht
heiraten sie können es sich nicht
leisten zu heiraten weil man von ihnen
als man erwartet dass sie den großteil
der heirats kosten tragen und hochzeiten
sind sehr teuer geworden weil sie die
konsumkultur wieder spielen sie können
also nicht heiraten wenn sie nicht
heiraten können ist es sehr schwierig
aus dem elternhaus auszuziehen wenn sie
nicht heiraten können ist es auch
spielen spazieren zu leben
ich sage im buch zum beispiel dass es
für eine durchschnittliche junge
arabische personen in der regel
unmöglich ist jemanden mit nach hause zu
bringen
sie kann keine beziehungen pflegen wie
man sie im westen kennt man darf keinen
sex haben keine kinder
insbesondere für junge männer aber auch
für junge frauen bedeutet diese zustand
ein aufschieben des erwachsenwerdens
wie wollen sie erwachsen werden wenn die
meilensteine des erwachsenenlebens
unerreichbar sind
heute befinden sich viele junge menschen
außerhalb der zitadelle unverheiratet
viele von ihnen möchten raten was aus
verschiedenen gründen nicht bild wie
sollen sie ihre sexuellen rechte
wahrnehmen und etwas was ja getan wird
was sie auch beschreiben ist es gibt
sehr sehr viel analsex in diesen
regionen weil die frau ja auch ihre
jungfräulichkeit bewahren müssen
und sie schreiben sogar dass es in
ländlichen regionen vorkommt dass junge
paare nicht einmal wirklich wissen wenn
die dann verheiratet sind wie man jetzt
diese kinder macht das kann man sich ja
eigentlich fast nicht vorstellen
wir haben in den meisten unserer schulen
im arabischen raum praktisch keinen
sexualunterricht es ist schwierig junge
menschen wissen nicht viel über
sexualität
ich kann nur ihm ist eine geschichte
eine junge frau kam zu mir studentin an
einer der top universitäten in ägypten
sie kam und sagte ich muss sie etwas
fragen ich bin frisch verlobt und möchte
wissen ob ich schwanger werden kann wenn
mein verlobter vor der klimaanlage
stellen
sie stellte er in paragraphen und es
zeigte sich der einzige sexualunterricht
den diese junge frauen je erhalten hatte
war über die formierung von schlimmsten
so glaubte sie dass spermien wie die
pollen irgendwie von ihrem verlobten
sechs spielen sind sie irgendwie
befruchten ist das lustig aber auch
tragisch weil es ganz direkt das ausmaß
der sexuellen ignoranz widerspricht die
sich etwa auch in überzogenen
erwartungen beim eingehen
daraus entstehen viele probleme
so sehen wir in verschiedenen arabischen
ländern hohe scheidungsraten und
speziell in der golfregion wegen
sexueller unverträglichkeit in den
ersten tagen der was den annalen sex
angeht den sie erwähnt haben das ist ein
sehr interessanter punkt der wunde punkt
wenn sie so wollen weil er in der tat
ein größeres problem reflektiert eines
der themen das ich in meinem buch
diskutiere ist die doppelmoral der
grundsatz dass im christentum und im
islam und im judentum in den wichtigsten
religionen der region männer an frauen
vor der heirat keusch bleiben müssen wir
leben aber in patriarchalen wo jungs
jungs sind sie haben sex vor der heirat
und die leute stellen sich bloß nicht zu
viel von ihnen erwartet man dass sie in
ihrer hochzeitsnacht mit einem intakten
jungfernhäutchen antreten
dabei geht es nicht um jungfräulichkeit
als ausdruck von käufern es geht die
anatomische jungfräulichkeit ist
irgendwie furchtbar schon nur zum lesen
sie beschreiben zum beispiel die in
ländlichen gebieten die entjungferung
von einer hebamme vorgenommen wird mit
einem tuch und einem stift und sie macht
diese entjungferung und zeigt nach ihrer
blutende tuch und die familie guckt zu
da frage ich mich dann was heißt ein
privat
in diesen kulturen die liefer steht man
privates überhaupt kein konzept so dass
dieser brauch den meldung
doch leider die nennt ist ein
rückläufiges phänomen zur zeit meiner
großmutter war das weit verbreitet heute
viel weniger was wir sehen ist eine
andere form von doch lag war der die
familie oft in der hochzeitsnacht kommt
um das touchieren zu holen wenn die
hochzeit vollzogen wird soll die braut
in folge der impfung von blut und die
familie nimmt dieses tuch und zeigt es
den nachbarn und weiteren
familienmitgliedern
dabei geht es um die familienehre und
das ist letztlich die krux die weibliche
jungfräulichkeit noch einmal es geht um
den schein nicht um die tat sächlich
jungfräulichkeit
aber davon abgesehen zeigt es auch dass
der körper einer frau nicht ihr allein
gehört das ist keine privatangelegenheit
sondern eine sache der familie und der
familienehre
das ist in der tat sehr interessant denn
es ist sehr schwierig über sexuelle oder
individuelle rechte zu sprechen wenn sie
in der gesellschaft nicht als individuum
gäste sie werden als teil eines
kollektivs als teil ihrer familie
betracht eine libanesische sechs
wahlrechts aktivistin sagte zu mir was
redest du über sexuelle rechte ich habe
keine persönlichen rechte im staats
register bin ich als tochter meines
vaters aufgeführt werde ich heiraten
wäre ich die frau meines ehemannes mich
kriegt es nicht als individuum wie also
kann ich diese rechte wahrnehmen wenn
die gesellschaft nicht entsprechend
strukturiert ist
diese aspekte sexualität widerspiegelt
also wie schon erwähnt übergeordneten
fragen der politischen strukturen unsere
gesellschaften diese strukturen und wie
man die anfangs ändern könnte und die
ändern müssen inwiefern darüber möchte
ich nachher gleich noch mit ihm sprechen
wenn wir mal noch wirklich beim
sexualleben sozusagen bleiben also
dieses buch erzählt ganz viele
geschichten
sie sagen am anfang aber auch eigentlich
ist das arabisch als hocharabisch
stubenrein es gibt gar keine griffe für
penis wie orgasmus für masturbation für
analverkehr
aber wie haben sie denn diese gespräche
geführt
wer definitiv wir haben sprache dafür
das problem ist dass ein großteil der
heutigen ausdrücke zu sechs die sprache
der straße ist und viele frauen die
schon allein beim thema sexualität in
verlegenheit geraten wegen der
doppelmoral und all dem sind doppelt
irritiert weil sie die sprache als sehr
wohl geher empfinden und es ihnen
peinlich zugebracht und halten sie sich
vor augen die frauen haben alles das
schlechte frau zu gelten als frau die
nicht respektabel ist weil sie über
diese dinge spricht diese begriffe
einfach nicht in den mund nehmen
faszinierende tatsache ist dass wir vor
1000 jahren ganze wörterbücher 26 auf
arabisch
das cover des buchs zeigen das ist
nämlich eine sehr interessante
illustration diese kalligraphie wurde
von einem sehr talentierten irakischen
kalligraphen namens wissenschaft
geschaffen
sie zeigt eindeutig den körper einer
frau interessant ist dabei dass diese
kalligraphie aus arabischen wörtern
bestimmt diese stammen aus einem wörter
die aus dem zehnten oder elften
jahrhundert in dem steht dass es im
arabischen über 1000 begriffe gibt ja
wir hatten ganze wörterbücher über sex
oft ihr gemüse mineralien für jedes ding
unter der sonne hatten wir eine
grafische sword um homosexuellen kontext
zu beschreiben
es war fantastisch wie sehr unsere
heutigen gesellschaften erstarrt sind
zeigt die tatsache dass viele gebildete
leute wenn sie über sex sprechen wollen
ihr französisch oder englisch brauchen
als arabisch oder sogar hebräisch des
palästinensers war in israel leben
sie brauchen lieber eine andere sprache
will man nun diese tabus in gruppen
ansprechen muss man erst eine
ausdrucksweise finden um mit frauen und
männern auf arabisch über sex zu
sprechen
das buch ja auch davon erzählen sie auch
dass es diese unglaubliche bewegung gab
diesen verlust auch dieser sprache
dieser kultur noch gar nicht so lange
hier sie erwähnen zb gustave flaubert
den autor von madame bovary der eine
reise gemacht hatten
und um 58 herum dieses buch geschrieben
hat 13 orient und in glühenden farben
seine sexuellen eskapaden schildert auch
sehr viele homosexuelle beziehungen
erscheint ganz begeistert gewesen zu
sein von diesen erlebnissen jeder hat um
ehrlich zu sein flaubert war eine art
sex tourismus 19 jahrhundert genau man
kann es genauso austauschen aber um
einen sex touristen um 6 uhr ist sein zu
können braucht man ja sozusagen auch das
anschauungsmaterial im entsprechenden
land und das gab es ja in dieser zeit es
gab diese ganze eben kultur es gab die
haare es gab diese bilder die die ja
auch immer noch vom hafen von vom orient
haben eine sehr sehr große sinnlichkeit
warum ging da verloren
eine sehr kurze sehr komplexe frage ich
muss zu dem ausführen es war nicht nur
für b mein vater wurde in den 1930 er
jahren in ägypten geboren
wenn ich zum beispiel die geschichten
seiner jugendzeit in den 19 50er jahren
höre oder die geschichten meiner
großmutter in diesem buch zitiere ich
viele sprichworte meiner großmutter
dienen dorf nördlich von kairo
aufgewachsen ist
sie ist auf dem land aufgewachsen und
hatte doch diesen sehr direkten und
offenen zugang zur sexualität heute bei
meinen verwandten ist das alles viel
länger
man muss also nicht zurück in die alte
geschichte um eine offenere einstellung
gegenüber sexualität zu finden
in unserer gegend hatten wir seit den
zeiten des propheten mohammed und er war
selber teil davon eine sehr offene
diskussion rund um sex es gab natürlich
sehr wenig das wären 1000 jahren in
diesem wundervollen arabischen erotik
bücher nicht diskutiert worden wäre
dazu gehören der parfümierte garten oder
ein buch das viele abend
kennen dürften tausendundeine nacht
viele hochgradig sexuell aufgeladene
geschätzt wir waren also sehr oft die
tabuisierung beginnt im neunzehnten
jahrhundert und es ist kein zufall dass
dies für viele länder im arabischen raum
auch die zeit der kolonisation durch
europa ist die europäischen gesetze
brachten eine bestimmte auffassung von
sexualität mit die von den oberschichten
die mit ihnen in kontakt kamen
übernommen wurde
interessanterweise wurde dies auch teil
des diskurses über islamischen
fundamentalismus der in den 19 20er
jahren in ägypten statt
der kunde der muslimischen bruderschaft
zum beispiel fragt in seinen schriften
wie kommt es dass wir von diesen fremden
überrannt worden
vielleicht weil wir vom weg unsere
religiösen gesetze abgekommen sind
vielleicht wegen unserer sexuellen
neigung vielleicht haben die abendländer
recht wenn sie sagen dass wir zu offen
sind weil wir jegliche formen von
sexualität erlauben in speziellen
homosexualität vielleicht müssen wir
damit aufhören und strickt agieren
das hat im lauf des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts an boden gewonnen
insbesondere seit den späten 19 70er
jahren mit dem aufschwung des
islamischen fundamentalismus und der
wahhabitischen interpretation des islam
in saudi arabien die dann in den rest
der region exportiert wurde
wir haben also eine verengung auf die
religion die stark mit politik und
wirtschaft verknüpft ist
ich sage in meinem buch das wir auf
unserer vergangenheit als araber und
muslime zurück blicken müssen und auf
die relative leichtigkeit unseres
damaligen umgangs mit sexualität nicht
weil ich eine art sexuelle salafisten
bin die an die rückkehr in ein
mythisches goldenes zeitalter der
sexuellen toleranz glaubt sondern weil
wenn leute wie ich und viele andere im
arabischen raum für mehr offenheit
gegenüber sechs kämpfen und dann die
konservativen kommen und sagen hier
verkauft uns an den westen
dann können wir ihnen antworten nein wir
haben den beweis dass wir recht arabisch
sind ehrlich gesagt echter muslim sein
bedeutet eine viel pragmatischere viel
tolerante haltung gegenüber sexualität
einzunehmen als das was ihr als konnte
die predigt junge leute sollten das
wissen über ihren typischen bioware war
und was stellt sich auch die frage wie
verändert sich denn eigentlich die welt
und ein indikator oder sich dinge
verändern nicht da in vielen ländern
bezüglich vieler dinge immer wieder die
popkultur und in diesem zusammenhang
haben sie mir auch erzählt von einem
libanesischen sänger der offen zu seiner
homosexualität steht und darüber singt
es ist maria leila und wir schauen uns
einen ausschnitt an auf einem video
[Musik]
in diesem lied singt der sänger davon
wie schwierig es ist den rollenbildern
gefangen zu sein und wie er eigentlich
gerne seinen man den heiraten möchte
treu bleiben möchte kann man den osten
über solche dinge über homosexualität
singen und auch diese videos angucken
wenn gleichzeitig homosexualität
dermaßen geächtet wird
malaria ist eine fantastische band wir
nennen das auf englisch auch eine in die
welt sie sind den arabischen raum sehr
beliebt und haben viele fans dabei
handelt es sich allerdings nur um eine
bestimmte gruppe von leuten
es ist keine massen popularität die
gruppe ist für die arabische welt nicht
was die boygroup one direction im westen
interessant ist dass sie diese themen
aufnehmen und es gibt noch andere
künstler die das tun was die
homosexualität anbelangt die öffnung des
internets
das ist eine wirklich guten seiten des
arabischen frühlings der in so vielen
anderen bereichen gescheitert ist
wir haben beobachtet dass sich junge
menschen vermehrt übers internet
verbinden
wenn sie den cyberspace untersuchen das
internet wenn sie so wollen
dann findet man dort mittlerweile einen
äußerst lebendigen dialog von menschen
mit alternativen sexuellen orientierung
die gleichgeschlechtliche beziehungen
haben oder alternative identitäten
bezüglich geschlecht sie haben zb ihrer
eigenen web magazin sie haben
diskussions kanäle viele sind sehr aktiv
es kommt darauf an wo im arabischen raum
sie sind aber in tunesien zum beispiel
dessen politische landschaft vielfältig
ist gibt es vor ort sehr lebendiges
starke gruppen die versuchen für
menschen mit alternativen sexualität in
der gesellschaft einen raum zu schaffen
sie sind im cyberspace sehr aktiv und
schaffe es ich muss sagen es ist nicht
ohne risiko ich weiß dass viele männer
und frauen zum beispiel apps benutzen
etwa brian da um leute ihres geschlechts
zu treffen für den aufriss sache ist man
muss das sehr sehr diskret tun
nicht dass die leute nicht wüssten dass
es homosexualität gibt in unseren
gesellschaften natürlich gibt es sie
interessante ist wenn sie unsere
schriften über sexualität anschauen
viel dreht sich darum die genüsse der
homosexualität der westen kritisierte
die arabische sexual kultur sie seien
offen und heute werden wir als sehr
repressiv gesehen also ja die leute
sprechen darüber problematisch ist dass
es von regierungen oft als werkzeug zur
kontrolle missbraucht wird so kenne ich
in ägypten junge männer die apps nutzen
gleichzeitig müssen sie vorsichtig sein
weil auch die regierung das internet
beobachtet wir hatten einige fälle wo
schwule männer und transsexuelle
menschen ins gefängnis gesteckt wurden
obwohl wir in ägypten gar kein gesetz
haben dass solche aktivitäten
kriminalisiert es ist also ein sehr
heikler balanceakt ein punkt der mir
dabei wichtig ist wenn sie mit leuten im
arabischen raum sprechen die versuchen
größerer akzeptanz und toleranz an dem
platz weil diese vielfältigen
bevölkerungsgruppen in der gesellschaft
zu erreichen
schauen sie wir wollen nicht
schwulenrechte nach westlichem stil wir
wollen keine schwulen paraden wir suchen
nicht nach der freiheit für ein coming
out sondern nach der freiheit die uns
erlaubt drinnen zu bleiben und hinter
verschlossenen türen zu tun was wir
wollen
deshalb verzichte ich in meinem buch auf
dem begriff sexuelle freiheit ich
spreche von sexuelle offenheit sexuelle
toleranz sexuelle erfüllung mir aber von
sexuelle befreiung weil dies im westen
eine ganz bestimmte bedeutung hat sie in
arabischen gesellschaften anders
gedeutet wird
die gemeinschaft ein stückweit
wahrscheinlich wichtiger ist dass man
tolle gemeinschaft bleibt sie selber
sind ja wirklich eine surfen der
zwischen den welten sie leben sowohl in
kairo wien london sich in den körper
geboren und aufgewachsen ihr vater ist
natürlich wurde in england wären spinnen
kann er darauf gewartet und ihre mutter
ist britin vater ägypter selber sind sie
muslime das heißt für sie ganz
persönlich würden sie sagen genau darum
geht es wir wollen nicht sexuelle
freiheit im westlichen sinne sondern wir
wollen leben das was uns überzeugt aber
eigentlich in diesen engen schranken als
teil einer gemeinschaft die vielleicht
gewisse dinge anders sieht ist
für sie persönlich genug im arabischen
raum ist der begriff sexuelle rechte
sowohl interessant ja auch problematisch
mit dem recht auf sexualität meinen wir
das recht auf ein sicheres lustvolles
und befriedigendes sexualleben ohne
gewalt diskriminierung und nötigung
leute im arabischen raum vor allem
konservative sagen das ist ein
westliches konstrukt ein westlicher
import es widerspricht unseren werten
und traditionen
tatsache ist aber dass die menschen rund
um den globus genau das wollen auch im
arabischen raum
vielleicht aber definieren sie lust von
ganz ich fragte zum beispiel viele junge
frauen im arabischen raum
möchtet ihr die gleiche freiheit sex vor
der ehe zu haben wie die frauen im
westen und die antwort war nein das ist
nicht die freiheit die wir suchen
ich will vor der ehe jungfrau bleiben
weil es gegen meinen glauben ist
christlich muslimische oder jüdisch
außerhalb der ehe beziehung zu haben was
ich will meine definition von sexuellen
rechten ist das mein fühlen meine eigene
angelegenheit ist und nicht jene meiner
familie und das bringt uns zurück zu
ihrem punkt betreffende intimität wie
viele menschen im arabischen raum ein
wichtiges thema weil frauen und männer
sich davor scheuen oder sex zu reden
sogar in der ehe diese frauen sagt mir
was unseren der sechs kultur des westens
gefällt ist nicht dass man vor der
hochzeit sex haben kann wir glauben
nicht dass die gehen dadurch besser
werden
eine frau sagte ich glaube nicht das ist
eine gute idee ist und die er deshalb
besser wird schauen sie sich madonna und
ihre vielen männer an was ich an der
westlichen sexual kultur mag ist die
tatsache dass es offenbar mehr respekt
mehr kommunikation mehr vertrautheit in
den beziehungen zwischen ehepartnern im
westen gibt als in unserer kultur das
ist was sie aus filmen also mich die
perfekte warnung auf wir es kommt darauf
an wie man diese begriffe definiert und
wie man vorgeht um sie zu erreichen
ich weiß dass leute im westen sehr oft
denken dass arabische frauen unterdrückt
sind und sich nicht selber ausdrücken
können
in vielen bereichen stimmt das aber ich
kenne zum beispiel frauen
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel
im zentrum von kairo findet man diese
fantastischen dessous läden mit ihren
frivolen kreationen
sie finden zb bhs die wenn man drauf
drückt den song old mcdonald s -fan
spielen einfach unglaublich
fantasievolle kreationen
ich war in diesen läden und ich traf die
frauen die dort einkaufen viele von uns
ja gerade mit bedecktem kopf
die meisten frauen in ägypten sind noah
gabe viele von ihnen sogar monopol
sie tragen auch gesichtsschleier und ich
fragte sie was tut ihr hier
und sie sagten weiß du schon für uns
wäre es beschämend unseren männern zu
sagen wir wollen sex aber ich kann meine
aufgeputschte frivole unterwäsche
anziehen und meinem mann damit klar
zeigen heute nacht das ist ein weiterer
wichtiger punkt das funktioniert nicht
nur im schlafzimmer sondern auch
aussagen ja für frauen gibt es viele
einschränkungen im gesetz in der familie
und in der gesellschaft
trotzdem finden frauen oft einen weg und
bekommen was sie wollen
sie müssen das bloß etwas anders
anpacken kann ja vorhin erwähnt dass das
internet seine guten seiten haben kann
so beispielsweise eben diese songs die
man sich angucken kann portale auf dem
sich menschen mit einer anderen
sexuellen orientierung treffen können
sich austauschen können
es gibt auch von einer niederländischen
firma aus eine multimediale plattform
die heißt live matches die schalten
verschiedene aufklärungs videos auf
themen rund um thema sexualität
versuchen darüber relativ objektiv zu
informieren einfach informationen
bereitzustellen
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich aber auch
die pornoindustrie und wir wissen
beispielsweise das polo portale die
power hub in pakistan welt war die
höchsten krieg raten erreichen
und da frage ich sie auch auf eine frau
die ja relativ feministisch eingestellt
ist wie gehen sie denn damit um
einerseits kann er sagen das ist gut das
internet ist offen und frei zeigt dinge
auch bringt auch informationen auf der
anderen seite wird auf diesen portalen
natürlich auch ein frauenbild
vorgestellt mit dem jetzt aus
feministischer warte heraus vielleicht
auch einiges an kritik verbunden sein
müsste jetzt sicher
das ist leider nicht allein ein
arabisches phänomen das ist eine globale
sorge was ich zum internet sagen kann zb
dieses portal dass wir hier auf arabisch
sehen die übersetzung lautet also pro
tag ab was soviel heißt wie liebe ist
kultur und das stimmt ehrlich gesagt ist
das die eindrücklichste entwicklung in
bezug auf sexuelle ausdrucksformen auf
arabisch die wir in den letzten tausend
jahren gesehen haben
ganz klar es ist ein wundervolles portal
weil es nicht nur informationen bietet
das ist auch ein youtube kanal eine
facebook-seite ein twitter feed es gibt
einen dialog sie haben mitwirkende
größtenteils frauen und sie haben männer
und frauen die sich im internet über
unglaublich heikle themen austauschen
was im eigenen schlafzimmer sehr
schwierig werden
und nun führen sie dieses gespräch im
virtuellen raum
deshalb ist diese entwicklung so wichtig
und es geht nicht bloß um sex es geht um
intimität um beziehungen und
gleichwertig adorno ist ein problem
es gibt im ganzen arabischen raum
terabyte von porno die runtergeladen
werden von männern mit interesse
geschaut und natürlich auch von frau
aber es ist viel schlimmer wenn die
familie herausfindet dass die tochter
pornos schaut was wenn der sohn es tut
das gehört zur doppelmoral porno hat
einen interessanten effekt einen
zerstörerischen effekt wie überall auf
der welt ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel wir
haben in ägypten einen brauch bekannt
unter dem begriff weibliche
genitalverstümmelung in ägypten nennen
wir es beschneidung von frauen im
wesentlichen bedeutet das dass die
genitalien eines mädchens im alter von
neun bis zwölf in ägypten sehr
verbreitet ja die ziffern sind immer
noch hoch das betrifft rund 70 prozent
der mädchen zwischen 15 und 17 es sind
viele
gleichzeitig waren es vor zehn bis 15
jahren noch 90 prozent
man sieht also fortschritte in der
ausrottung der grund weshalb ich das
erwähne
man macht das aus verschiedenen gruppen
ein hauptmotiv ist jedoch dass man
glaubt man könne damit die frauen
im arabischen raum rasiert unter männern
eine große angst dass sie sexuell nicht
genügen und die frauen nicht befriedigen
können
an diesem punkt ist es wirklich
interessant zu sehen wie weibliche
sexualität im islam wahrgenommen wird
frauen werden nicht das passive sexuelle
kreaturen gesehen sondern mit einem
sexualtrieb der stärker ist als jener
der männer
ja ja absolut dann machen sie das fest
wenn die sagen das ist im islam so die
haben koran haben wir eine stelle eine
bestimmte geschichte die diese tatsache
sehr klar illustriert wie er war der
kuss und schwiegersohn des propheten
mohammed ali der den schiitischen islam
gründete hatte einen interessanten
spruch er sagte gott schuf zehn arten
der lust neun davon gabel den frau und
ein
es gibt also diese lange geschichte
echter angst vor der weiblichen
sexualität weil diese so stark ist wie
können wir im bett bestehen diese erotik
bücher die ich erwähne endlos viele
kapitel darüber wie sich männer für die
großen acht steigern können
weil man eine verwirrung der
gesellschaft befürchtet wenn die frauen
nicht befriedigt werden
darauf baut die beschneidung auf man
glaubt dass eine junge frau wenn man
ihre klitoris verstümmelt weniger
sexuelle lust verspürt dass sie kaum sex
außerhalb der ehe suchen oder exzessive
sexuelle forderungen an ihren ehemann
stellen wird aber das ist ja interessant
während wir im westen oft das bild haben
und auch perpetuieren in unzulässiger
weise aber oft dieses bild zeichnen von
rastlos sexuellen mann im arabischen
raum der dauernd will und dauernd kamen
wie ein tier über andere herfällt das
ist ja das was oft als unglaublich
vorurteils beladenes bild gezeichnet
wird ist es im arabischen raum zum teil
umgekehrt also sie haben den eindruck
die frau sei so im arabischen raum sieht
man das ganze ziemlich anders ich gebe
ihnen ein weiteres beispiel
es gibt dieses literatur ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob sie es auch auf deutsch
und auf englisch sind es die wüsten
roman die ersten wissen romane
entstanden im frühen
20ten jahrhundert mit dem berühmten buch
von edith meinhart der bei ihrem
hauptgeschäft der scheich erlangte in
der populärkultur berühmtheit wegen des
films mit rudolph valentino
er ist der arabische aristokrat mit
pferd und kopfbedeckungen flatternde
kleider gehüllt er kommt unten nimmt
sich die westliche frau erlebt sie flach
und schließlich verwandelt die westliche
frau die entführt überfallen und
missbraucht worden war
diesen vor sexueller kraftstrotzenden
arabischen man in einen sehr
ordentlichen es gab einige dieser bücher
meinen ägyptischen und arabischen
freundinnen und sagte könntet ihr das
lesen
viele meiner freundinnen sich darüber
beklagten geschlecht die männer im bett
war dass sie oft wie agra nehmen mussten
dass sie es nicht beendet hatten
sie waren nicht befriedigt meine
freundinnen die perfekt englisch
sprechen kamen zurück und sagten glauben
westliche frauen tatsächlich dass männer
so sind ehrlich und eine frau sagte mir
ich verstehe nicht dieses buch
beschreibt wie diese arabische scheich
die frau befriedigte bis sie zufrieden
gestellt war
und dann erst dann ließ er von ihr meine
freundin sagte lass mich erzählen wir es
mit meinem mann ist es dauert fünf
minuten
es gibt kein vorspiel es gibt keine
französischen küste dann schläft er ein
und anschließend schaut der fährt diese
fragen waren also rinn zufrieden mit
ihrem sexualleben
die männer haben angst nicht zu genügen
und sie sind werden der unsicherheit
auch sehr verletzlich sie haben keine
jobs in ein job und für eine frau sorgen
ist aber ein schlüsselfaktor für
männlichkeit
ich möchte gerne noch einmal etwas
zurück und die beschneidung des
geschäfte abschließen weil das
zusammengehört es sind frauen die
entscheiden ob töchter beschnitten
werden oder nicht
männer haben dazu nicht zu sagen es sind
mütter und großmütter die entscheiden ob
eine tochter beschnitten wird im
allgemeinen wussten männer bisher nicht
ob ihre frauen beschnitten sind weil sie
keinen sechsmal erziehung haben also
gehen sie irgendwie davon aus dass ihre
frauen beschnitten sind
der interessante einfluss von porno ist
nun dass diese männer westliche pornos
schauen und sie wissen dass westliche
frauen nicht beschnitten sind wenn sie
also einen baum
gesehen haben mit einer westlichen frau
die mit zwei oder drei männern
gleichzeitig sex hat sagen sie schaue
ich habe es dir gesagt das ist der grund
weshalb wir unsere mädchen beschneiden
müssen diese westlichen frauen sind
nicht geschnitten und sie treiben es mit
allen deshalb müssen wir den sexualtrieb
unserer frauen kontrollieren
aber ist es nicht irgendwie verrückt ich
meine es gibt ja diese schriften von
etwa zeit der bücher geschrieben hat
technologische bücher über den
sogenannten orientalismus vorwurf dass
die im vest nehmen einer bestimmten art
und weise über den sogenannten orient
sprechen und unglaublich viele
vorurteile perpetuieren das ist diese
ganze postkoloniale idee dass man
eigentlich immer in diesen
kolonialistischen gedankengut bleibt
gleichzeitig scheint es ja umgekehrt
auch so zu sein also im arabischen raum
blickt man auf den sogenannten westen
und hat die bilder die im westen
irgendwie da gegeben sein sollen und
sehr sehr klare vorstellung davon wie
wir im westen sind wie kommen wir denn
aus diesen vorurteilen überhaupt hier
heraus ich frage mich manchmal wie es da
eigentlich verständigung möglich
aber da optimistisch sein ich bin
optimistisch ob schon ereignisse wie
jene in köln zu denken geben und die
kluft klar aufzeigen die es zwischen der
östlichen und der westlichen wahrnehmung
gibt aber ich glaube dass plattformen
via lopatka v die vermehrte bgs nur
junge frauen und männer mit anderen
sexuellen kulturen sowie das wachsende
verständnis fortschritt bringen
deshalb bin ich langfristig optimistisch
dass man sich besser verstehen
ich glaube aber es braucht auch mehr
respekt die idee dass es nur eine art
geht wie man sein sexuelles leben
gestalten kann und dass der westen die
sexuelle revolution erfunden hat und
deshalb der rest der welt nun hinterher
läuft finde ich falsch revolution im
westen war nicht wie ein helikopter der
von einem gelände voller tabus in die
lüfte der freiheit und schwebte
kohl s transportflugzeuge die riesigen
sie brauchten eine wirklich lange
startbahn um abzuheben und diese
startbahn wurde aus jahrhunderte langen
politischen wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen reformen gebaut dann das
flugzeug ab wir im arabischen raum
vielleicht haben wir im moment noch
nicht einmal ein flugzeug und wir haben
definitiv keine stadtbahn aber diese
wird aktuell gebaut das ist eine der
spannenden seiten bei allen problemen im
nachgang zum arabischen frühling
es gibt veränderungen vor ort sie sind
klein sie brauchen zeit man muss ihm
zeit geben damit es nachhaltig ist diese
gesellschaften vertragen keine schnellen
veränderungen aber wenn unser flugzeug
abhebt fliegt es nicht unbedingt in die
gleiche richtung
ziel ist ein erfülltes sexualleben frei
von gewalt diskriminierung unnötigen
vielleicht erreichen wir das auf einem
ganz anderen weg außenstehende müssen
das respektieren ist gleichzeitig müssen
die menschen im arabischen raum
respektieren dass andere kulturen das
gleiche ziel anstreben und ihrerseits
einen anderen weg wählen sie selber
haben köln jetzt schon noch einmal ins
spiel gebracht sprechen wir noch einmal
über köln die feministin alice schwarzer
hat gewarnt gesagt die ganzen
migrationsbewegungen die würden
einhergehen mit einem import männlicher
gewalt was sagen sie dazu
noch einmal die ereignisse in köln sind
äußerst bedauerlich und wie ich vorher
gesagt habe als jemand der genau weiß
was sexuelle belästigung ist und wie sie
sich anfühlt fühle ich mit den frauen
dem ausgesetzt war
trotzdem wenn wir nur die ereignisse von
köln betrachten es wurden 1000 fälle
rapportiert 400 davon als sexuelle
angriffe
bisher wurden rund 40 männer
viele von ihnen nordafrikanischer
herkunft und etwa zehn oder so sind in
untersuchungshaft
ich verstehe dass es in deutschland
große beunruhigung gibt wegen der
migrationswellen die kommen man darf
aber nicht vergessen dass die männer die
angeklagt sind die attacken in köln
begangen zu haben keine flüchtlinge sind
und doch sind flüchtlinge jetzt mit
gemeint bei diesen rechtsaußen parolen
alle arabischen männer sind gefährlich
ja alle muslimischen männer sind
gefährlich und wir müssen sie draußen
halten
ich stelle das herz auf den kampf wenn
wir die vorfälle während des karnevals
in köln betrachten wo sie eine anzahl
ich glaube es gab etwa 60 rapportierte
fälle von sexuellen übergriffen
diese wurden nicht von parabenen männern
begangen nehmen wir an es waren deutsche
männer wenn wir das nun umdrehen und
sagen alle deutschen männer sind
gefährlich sie sind sexuelle raubtiere
und wissen sie was noch es ist der
lutheran ismus ihre religion macht sie
gefährlich
natürlich würden die leute sagen das ist
vielseitig wie kannst du von einer
kleinen gruppe auf die masse schließen
genau das geschieht in diesem fall ich
verstehe weshalb leute im westen zu
fühlen
man denke nur an das den islamischen
staat und an all die abscheulichen
sexuellen verbrechen die sie zum
beispiel an jesidischen frauen begangen
haben
völlig klar dass man so im westen nicht
ein image von sexueller aufklärung und
toleranz erhält wichtig ist sich vor
augen zu halten dass nur ein kleiner
bruchteil aller männer sich in diesen
tätern widerspiegelt und die gefahr des
verallgemeinern wenn wir uns erinnern
vor sechs monaten war das bild das wir
vom arabischen männlichen flüchtling
halten jenes von mailand kulis vater der
arme junge der ertrunken ist und der
trauernde vater
das war die vorstellung der arabische
mann der alles riskiert hat um seine
familie zu retten
das war vor setzen
und jetzt das bild des arabischen
flüchtlings der entweder im gefängnis
oder alt trägt oder einen deportation
befehl die projektion und zwar
allgemeine rung die spekulation ohne
beweise und informationen über arabische
männer und ihr leben das ist die gefahr
[Musik]
trotzdem stellt sich die frage wie
versuchen die oder viele viele fordern
jetzt irgendwelche integrationskurse
geben auch die sexuelle dimension nicht
einbeziehen das rollenverständnis mit
einbeziehen und die behörden in luzern
haben vor der luzerner fasnacht ein
faltblatt herausgebracht das haben sie
verteilt da sehen wir gewisse
erklärungen was man tun darf was man
nicht tun darf was in der schweiz
erlaubt ist was nicht im bereich
geschlechterrollen im bereich sexualität
und viele migrantinnen oder migranten
viele männer haben sich beleidigt
gefühlt eben durch diese generalisierung
wie sie es auch sagen und haben sich in
einem offenen brief an die bevölkerung
gewandt und dann die behörden und gesagt
das lassen wir uns nicht bieten wir
möchten darauf hinweisen dass sie nicht
alle in den gleichen topf geschmissen
werden leuchten
das kann ich sehr gut verstehen aber
stellt sich doch die frage was sollen
wir denn tun also was würden sie sagen
wären hilfreich im moment der sagen wir
mal integration der aufklärung des
sinnvollen zusammenlebens lassen sie
mich auf meinen früheren punkt zurück
gekommen den versuch informationen für
die diskussion betreffend dem arabischen
mann zu lieben
in meiner aktuellen forschung geht es in
der tat um die männer im arabischen raum
als ich sechs und die zitadelle schrieb
wurde mir klar dass ich recht viel über
weibliche sexualität wusste nicht aber
über die männer
was paradox ist weil die männer die
pfeiler unseres patriarchats it trotzdem
sprechen wir nur selten mit ihnen weil
sie als quelle von problemen gesehen
werden
sex wird mit problem gleichgesetzt mit
thabo restriktionen wenn sie so
betrachten sind die frauen auf der
empfängerseite die männer sind die täter
warum sollten wir mit denen reden
es gibt bemerkenswerte schritte zur
überwindung dieser tabus von vielen
basis organe
aktionen im arabischen raum und auf see
mehr gleichberechtigung der geschlechter
fest steht wir werden damit nicht sehr
weit kommen wenn wir nicht anfangen mit
den männern zu reden
der anfang des gesprächs mit den männern
besteht darin zu verstehen was wirklich
in ihrem leben geschieht zusammen mit
der ngo primondo die diese arbeit in
brasilien startete befragen ihn nun rund
10.000 männer und frauen in vier ländern
des arabischen raums in rocco ägypten
den palästinensischen gebieten und im
libanon
wir sprechen über männer und ihr leben
in allen bereichen männer als väter als
ehemänner asyl um ein vollständiges bild
zu erhalten vom druck den sie erfahren
das muss gemacht werden für die männer
die schlussendlich auswandern
viele dieser männer müssen auswandern
die region verlassen
leider aus wirtschaftlichen aus
politischen gründen werden sie nach
europa kommen wir müssen sie verstehen
als forschungsgruppe wollen wir in
europa eine vergleichbare studie über
migranten und männliche flüchtlinge
machen um eine bessere vorstellung zu
gewinnen was in deren leben vorgeht
sie können keine integrationsprogramme
durchführen und glauben dass sie wirksam
sind wenn sie nicht verstehen wie diese
männer über diese dinge denken aber
niemand hatte die zeit mit ihnen über
diese fragen zu sprechen
ich glaube der andere wichtige aspekt
für die erziehung der neuankömmlinge ist
dass man verbindung aufnehmen zu
basisgruppen im arabischen raum
wir haben viele ensi aus die für die
gleichstellung der geschlechter kämpfen
die unterschiedlichste formen von
sexuellen tabus angehen von der stellung
unverheirateter mütter über
sexualerziehung an den schulen bis zur
suche nach einem platz für homosexuelle
wir haben viele ausgebildete leute die
das im arabischen raum bieten
warum werden sie nicht mit den gruppen
in verbindung gesetzt die das in europa
tun
die versuchen das verhalten zu verändern
und zu verbessern ermögliche eine
kulturell angepasste ernährung sprich
mit diesen männern und frauen die an
kommen ich glaube dann wird veränderung
möglich
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die
arbeit die schon martha nussbaum und
matthias henn gemacht haben die immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen haben dass
viele der werte berlin gedenken diese
gesellschaften haben ganz andere werte
sich eigentlich bei genauerem studium
gezeigt hat das ist gar nicht so
der grundlegende wert hinten dran
ist eigentlich derselben uhr zeigt er
sich kulturell gesehen nachher in
verschiedenen facetten und trotzdem ist
es so wenn man sich das anschaut was der
world value regals zeigt das ist eine
große umfrage in verschiedenen
gesellschaften in dem die moralischen
wertvorstellungen verglichen werden
dann zeigt sich es sind eigentlich immer
die geschlechterrollen die am
unterschiedlichsten eingeschätzt werden
dort zeigen sich am meisten differenzen
und da stellt sich mir manchmal schon
die frage inwiefern müssten in gewisser
hinsicht auch einfach sehr vorsichtig
werden und sagen bevor wir da irgendwie
mit einem neuen inka realismus auf
andere leute zu gehen braucht es
vielleicht auch einfach so etwas wie
eine gewisse bescheidenheit vor den
unterschieden in der denke der menschen
wie sie sich nur einmal vor findet
gleichzeitig habe ich wahnsinnig angst
vor einer falschen intoleranz die einen
kniefall geht vor
menschenrechtsverletzungen in dieser
spannung sie meinen politisch korrekt
sein
ja genau vielleicht ist das die frage
was man politisch korrekt aber es ist
auch für mich immer wieder die frage wie
können die menschenrechtsverletzungen
klarerweise andrang dagegen vorgehen
ohne imperialistisch zu wecken
noch einmal das thema ist faszinierend
der sogenannte kampf der kulturen wie
ihn zum beispiel samuel huntington
beschrieben hat und sie haben recht
vor ein paar jahren gab es auch von
gallas eine interessante befragung
sie sprachen mit muslimischen migranten
in berlin paris und london sowie mit dem
rest der bevölkerung was sie
herausfanden ist genau was sie erwähnt
haben soll sind auf der gleichen seite
wenn es um rechtsstaatlichkeit geht um
beteiligung in der politik
meinungsfreiheit wo der unterschied
hervortrat war nicht nur bei den
geschlechterrollen sondern auch bei der
sexualität im arabischen raum haben wir
das problem dass wir keine positive
beschreibung haben für sexualität im
arabischen raum definieren viele leute
sex indem sie zurückweisen wasser
im westen kommt das wollen wir nicht und
das nicht und das nicht das ist westlich
nein sagen allein ist kein zugang zu
einem erfüllenden und glücklichen
sexualleben die aufgabe für uns vor ort
für mich und viele andere leute die in
diesem raum arbeiten bis zu versuchen
einen kulturell angepassten zugang zu
finden der diese werte von würde und
privatsphäre autonomie und freiheit
das ist nicht unvereinbar mit dem islam
es ist absolut möglich und in der tat
vor 1000 jahren fanden unsere vorfahren
einen weg diesen sex positiven zugang zu
schaffen der wenigstens manchen menschen
ein erfülltes sexualleben ermöglicht wir
müssen etwas finden das zu unserem
zeitalter passen müssen sie diese idee
mag interessant zahlen dass unsere werte
so weit auseinanderliegen ost und west
und niemals treffen sich die beiden
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel aus der
geschichte des islam es gab einen
ägyptischen islamischen gelehrten und
auch journalisten
sein name ist mohammed abdu er lebte im
19 jahrhundert für eine gewisse zeit
ging hamit abtun nach frankreich und
england er machte eine sehr interessante
bemerkung als er zurückkehrte er sagte
wissen sie im westen sei islam aber
keine muslime
und als ich in den osten zurückkehrte
sah ich muslime aber keinen islam
dabei wollte er sagen dass die werte des
islam kompatibel sind mit den werten der
westlichen demokratie in unseren ländern
sind die werte von politischen regimes
verdreht und verteilt worden sei es von
religiösen autoritäten konservativen
oder politischen diktaturen zum langen
weg der demokratisierung auf denen wir
noch nicht sehr weit gekommen sind
gehört dass wir diese werte wieder auf
die reihe bringen das ist nicht
unmöglich sie sind teil unserer
vergangenheit und können auch teil
unserer zukunft seien immer das phänomen
religion ist schlussendlich auch ein
stück weit das was man daraus macht
lassen sie nicht zum abschluss noch eine
frage stellen wie wir eigentlich im
westen uns selber wahrnehmen interessant
ist ja was in einer sehr freizügigen
bescheid gesellschaft leben
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass sehr viele
menschen bauen nicht mehr so viel sex
haben man beklagt allenthalben eine
große sexuelle unzufriedenheit gerade in
paarbeziehungen auch sind wir im westen
opfer geworden
eigenen freizügigkeit ich habe den
eindruck dass alle gesellschaften
weltweiten und ich bin weit gereist 46
und die zitadelle dass wir uns alle mehr
oder weniger in einem zustand sexueller
blockierung befinden einige mehr als
andere
der drang nach sexueller erfüllung
dauert ein leben das gilt auch für das
leben von gesellschaften
ich glaube wir haben viel auszutauschen
zu teilen
ich glaube man kann einiges von der
westlichen offenheit gegenüber
sexualität lernen
ich glaube die herausforderungen für
arabische gesellschaften und andere im
globalen süden ist es eine lokale
übersetzung zu finden die für aktuelle
und für kommende generationen sinn macht
sascha lobo hat im anschluss an köln
gesagt differenzierung ist zivilisation
schönefeld ich danke ihnen für dieses
differenzierende und differenzierte
gespräch vielen dank auch nächste woche
gibt es bei uns philosophischen
zündstoff dann nämlich begrüße ich sie
zur ersten ausgabe unseres neuen formats
dem philosophischen stammtisch fünfmal
im jahr diskutieren hier mit drei
philosophinnen und philosophen das
aktuelle zeitgeschehen nächsten sonntag
sprechen die unter anderem über die
flüchtlingskrise diskutieren sie mit und
senden sie mir ihre meinungen und fragen
dazu auf philosophie at treffpunkt ch
ich freue mich auf ihre zuschriften und
auf eine angeregte debatte bis nächste
woche also hoffentlich und jetzt einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]